first things first you who are being
recognized tonight for innovative work
shaping the future of music when you
hear that as an artist how does that
make you feel shaping the future person
like how does that make me
I don't even I'm like I'm like through
the roof I'm just I'm just happy about
it
you know I don't know what else I'm
supposed to be you know listen happy is
a good thing let's start there all right
when we choose that we're starting in a
good place
do you know who's presenting the award
tonight okay no is that the well we know
we I don't want to savour the surprise
if you didn't know I know how big a fan
of Julia she's been like one of the most
like one of the most appreciative like
human being in her presence and that she
carries and she gives to people I think
it's like just inspiring to like watch
her talk to anyone and I mean she's got
like Scott star power like if you're in
a room with her you're just like smiling
is America's Sweetheart true yes and she
has been free for some time which is so
wonderful and and you know just such an
honor and kids are so nice and it's just
like such a crazy honor to get to know
them at all yeah but I think I think if
you're if you're looking for a role
model carrying yourself through your
life the way that she carries herself
with the way she treats people you know
she presents herself it's just like so
admire the way she just like appreciates
art I guess and like just like energy I
don't know man have a favorite movie of
hers and you know I just saw Ben his
back so good right
her teeth are so nice summer years by
the way you know what thank you I
appreciate that my mother and all my
trips to the dentist would be happy to
hear that okay so I want to run down a
few accolades for you because the list
is long
okay second most streamed artists next
to ariana grande album debuted at number
one performed at Coachella I mean you're
on the cover of billboard my girl this
is life this is life I was I've been
having I've been having to talk about
myself in the third person because like
I don't know how to be like I just did
that I just did things like I got to be
like way more normal and cool the
collection it sounds like douchey but
it's just it's my only way of
understanding want to be like involved
in it and not almost an out-of-body
experience like you're almost looking at
yourself from the outside so you kind of
have to talk about yourself like you're
looking at that person over there but
can we talk about meeting Justin Bieber
at Coachella okay let's unpack this one
no but what did you say what did he say
could you collaborate in the future you
know what I don't even want to talk
about it he he's really sweet I think I
just want to let him live his life I'm
not gonna talk about him
you know he's doing his thing you let
him breathe you know what I'm saying
better breathe you are texting now with
Arianna right
could you guys collaborate in the future
Arianna is like a she's a boss she's
been real about she it is like she just
is so god man she's been through like I
I don't know if I have respect for
anyone like I have for her have you been
able to pick her brain at all about like
how do i navigate this yeah yeah I mean
just like naturally without being like
tell me how do you know what I'm saying
like she's just you can just tell she's
she knows what she's doing right and
like if she even if she doesn't realize
that she knows and it's it's really
impressive you know she's she just did
it so well
okay so we were just with Elton John
this morning and he said what he loves
right now is listening to things that
are good and new and he named dropped
you he specifically named dropped you so
what is that like hearing Elton John say
this is what I want to hear and that's
your music dude where is really sparkly
jackets
he wears sparkly ass jackets that's
crazy
he's cute he was actually one of the
first like people to show love I feel
like at the beginning I remember he
tweeted something right and he I don't
know I don't even remember he just he's
always been showing support since day
one a little bit so I just hope that
like if we have a career half as long as
he had that we're able to stay as
enthusiastic about new music as he is he
is so you know father of reinvention
yeah well he's reinvented himself a
million times but he's also just so
current and the music that he's
listening to like the amount of times
I've found a new artist and I go to his
Twitter and he's like posting about that
new art and I'm like wow that's really
like you know I'm 21 that dude is like
just killing it and and you know so
impressive I know you guys have to go
but can we can you just talk about your
music that you have coming very soon and
then there's music coming out this year
yeah yeah I like to put songs out like
one at a time like pretty frequently I
like to keep people fed yeah the way we
usually work is we make an album and
that takes however long it takes and
then as we're putting that album out I
record and write my own
and as we're putting my own stuff out we
refocus on new Billy music so it's a
balance
you guys make such good music though
because I thrive on energy and the
energy between y'all is bananas bananas
[Music]